bonjour et celle où vous suivez ces
manifestations un contre ce troisième
mandat controversé d'alpha condé quelle
est l'ambiance autour de vous
actuellement
eh bien écoutez à magali le
rassemblement est dorénavant terminer un
petit peu plus tôt ils étaient plusieurs
centaines ici au trocadéro à s'être
rassemblés pour protester contre ce
troisième mandat qu'alpha condé entend à
briguer en guinée alors face à la crise
politique que subit le pays pas question
pour la diaspora guinéenne de rester les
bras croisés il était un non seulement
venu réclamer à le départ d'alpha condé
a du pouvoir mais ils dénonçaient aussi
son bilan qu'il juge désastreux cela
fait dix ans qu'elle faconde est au
pouvoir il n'a jamais rien fait on veut
qu'elle faconde et s'en aille se sont
allés phrase que l'on a entendu un ici
tout là tout l'après-midi en boucle de
la part de ces manifestants je vous
propose de les écouter ce qu'il faut
savoir ce que tous les guinéens du monde
entier sont peinés par ce qui se passe
en guinée
mais alpha condé et ses sbires et tout
le gouvernement et tous les complices de
ce régime sont la bouche bée et ça c'est
extrêmement grave et on va le déclarer
jusqu'à ce qu'on obtienne l'alternance
faut pas s'étonner que les localisent
l'auxine l'occident soit envahi par des
réfugiés qui viennent de guinée donc
pour aider non il n'ya pas que l'afrique
qu'il faut aider à sion la nina guinée f
le dire la france et tous les pays
occidentaux rob aider à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus ces dictateurs qui reste en place
malgré l'opposition du peuple parce que
le peuple n'en veut pas la guinée est en
soif de justice
nous ne nous en avons marre nous avons
eu 10 ans d'alpha condé et en disant on
n'a pas vu un seul changement en disant
il n'y a pas d'électricité
en dix ans n'a pas d'hôpitaux en disant
n'y a pas de route
donc c'est à dire que pour faire 145 km
figurez vous qu on a besoin de faire 6
heures
six heures pour faire 145 km ça veut
dire que moi je prends mon vol de paris
roissy j'arrive à conakry plus vite que
quelqu'un qui fait qu'on écrit kindia
qui est l'équivalent de 145 135km merci
donc sans scandale nombreux sont ceux
aussi qui ont regretté le manque
d'intérêt de la communauté
internationale face aux événements et
qui se déroule en guinée voilà pour les
revendications de ce rassemblement qui
s'est déroulé de façon pacifique et qui
est dorénavant terminé merci beaucoup
restent elles pour toutes ces précisions
estelle farges en direct de la place du
trocadéro à paris